foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book uh changer oh your past change your
future and the new book listen to what's
on my mind the uh man this book is
absolutely going crazy it comes out one
week from now building a non-anxious
life one week it's going to be out and
uh that's why I got John on here for
this first segment because this book is
setting all kinds of publishing records
at Ramsay and sales it's doing really
good apparently there's some anxious
folk out there yeah can I tell you the
coolest thing that's happened so far the
numbers are amazing and they're fun like
no doubt about it making money is great
and helping people this many people
saying hey I'm helping helping that
number of people is what's important
yeah what's been really amazing Dave is
um as a part of any book sale you send
out
um Galley copies which are just for the
Press right and you know that and it's
I'm doing these interviews podcast
podcast Radio interviews from people all
over the place and we're getting on the
podcast and they're saying hey you got a
second I read this book and my wife and
I sat down I had a hard conversation
last night or I just pre-ordered three
of these books for my family members and
so the folks are getting the early early
drafts of these things yeah they're not
being a broadcaster they're being a
person they're turning it's it's it's
really powerful um if you turn media
people into humans this is a magical
book
so yeah it's it's um I'm getting excited
to get it out there man that's cool
anxiety is not the problem
right it's the symptom it's the fire
alarm going off that says something's
broken right and so you talk about the
six choices in your daily choices in the
book that we can make to uh you know
build a solid foundation in our life so
when something scary comes at us we can
uh be prepared instead of overwhelmed
with anxiety right and most people say
where I start where do I start where do
I start
you we've all heard of the phrase the
attention economy I think that is a
scandalously positive spin on what I
like to call the distraction economy or
the look over here economy and so we've
been trained for the last 25 to 50 years
if you've got a problem
it's somebody else's fault buy this
scroll this um run over here look over
here numb out Netflix it away instead of
getting to the root problem and the
challenge with that is your body knows
yeah your body knows it doesn't matter
how nice your cars are your body knows
you're probably about to get fired it
doesn't matter how many dates you've
been on your body knows my marriage has
fallen apart and so you have to start by
choosing reality and that's just step
one right what is the actual state of
your health when's the last time you got
a blood test when's the last time you
sat with a doctor and said I'm not
feeling great how overweight are you
when's the last time you sat with your
wife or your husband across the table
and said
we're not all right or when your kid
walks in their house and they just
immediately beeline into the room and
they slam their door and you just go oh
it's those teenagers your body knows
that's not right that's not right and so
you have to own reality choose reality
that's step one right and there's six of
those choices and we just we pull them
apart in the book and just say hey man
here's the problem
and here's how to fix it the good news
is if you order it in the last week here
before it actually comes out for twenty
dollars you get 75 worth of free bonus
items including instant access to Dr
John's talk smoke fire and freedom which
you did the other day in Chicago at the
Smart conference was a big hit the
e-book of building a non-anxious life in
the audiobook of building a non-anxious
life will also be delivered to you uh
next week when the book comes out all of
that for just twenty dollars uh next uh
one week or one week and one hour later
uh you won't be able to get those deals
as soon as Tuesday the third gets here
that's uh that's all gone it's just the
book is for sale at that point and uh so
hey we want to help you guys out this is
an important subject and this is a
fabulous treatment of an important
subject go to ramseysolutions.com hit
the bookstore get the 20 book building a
non-anxious life this week while you
still can with all of the add-ons it's a
great deal and um
you know we're real careful at Ramsey we
have a a uh a high percentage like a
hundred percent of our show of our books
are on the best seller list uh we're not
a publishing outfit that just prints
stuff and hope something works out we're
very very selective very careful and we
beat the snot out of these manuscripts
these authors the marketing plans the
whole thing to make sure that we're
actually serving you guys that way when
we bring you the next book you know it's
also going to be good it's not we're
just throwing crap out there to see if
you guys will get a shovel or not and I
was gonna say I've defended two
dissertations and I'd rather do that a
third one than sit before in front of
you guys and defend my manuscript again
y'all I mean it's it's yeah
we believe to be unclear as to be unkind
y'all are very clear very kind very
clear very kind I think you're wrong no
I love him it's already sucks you need
to get to the point iron sharpens iron
wow could you have said this in one page
instead of 114. yeah but yeah I mean
it's it's a it's a refinement process
but you end up with a book that's clean
and very clear and direct which is the
opposite of most of the publishing
industry and helpful and you know we're
not just throwing stuff out there on
paper to see if it'll work paper's too
dead come expensive to do that so
ramseysolutions.com
store you can hit the bookstore there uh
the store with all of our stuff in it
and pre-order this new book building a
non-anxious life you got one week to do
it and get all of the goodies so your
hope for this when someone reads it is
what my hope is someone who reads this
the first thing they do is they feel not
alone and
um I think most of us are spinning out
in our own minds in our own cars
um and our own behind our own headphones
thinking we're the only ones feeling
like this that our marriages are doing
ones like this so I want people to read
this book and not feel alone and I want
to provide a picture I tell a lot of
stories from calls I've had in my own
personal life
oh dude I'm not the only one and the
second one is I want people to have a
road map just to do something different
their parents did the best they could
they just had a limited amount of tools
in a tool kit the culture is telling
them in a completely disastrous other
thing to do this is a road map to build
a life
um that quite frankly you deserve it you
deserve to have peace in your life
because oh man life's hard life's hard
and so on those moments that when life's
not just slapping you around
and it's a map it's a guide it's a road
map now I think you might actually
discover that your Facebook friends
aren't real friends right right exactly
or you might just might be a revelation
for some of you our Facebook friends
would actually meet with you for coffee
or for a drink or for some nachos if
you'd actually just say hey date and
time here's where I'm gonna be maybe or
maybe not maybe you'd realize oh they're
not for real no I need to do something
different you might realize my marriage
is better than I thought it was and
while things are good we can start
playing for the next stage that's coming
if you think they're really good friends
let's just have a covered thing and see
if they show up exactly exactly yes
you'll find out who's real real fast
real fast
all right building a non-anxious life Dr
John deloney one weeks ago guys go get
it at ramseysolutions.com don't miss out
thanks John this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
glad you're here America thank you for
joining us Sarah is in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Sarah welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi thank you so much for having me how
are you better than I deserve what's up
um so I have a two-part question
um the first part of my question is at
what baby said do I
um figure out if I get term life
insurance I'm a single mom to two
daughters
um and then the second part of that
question is if it's worth it to me
um just based on the fact that
um the other parent
um my daughter's father and I are no
longer together
um and there's a history of domestic
violence so I don't necessarily trust
what will be done with life insurance
and my parents don't live in the country
um so I'm just wondering if that's a
viable option for me and what baby step
I would incorporate that to okay it's
not a baby step it's a now
it does not go on a baby step the life
insurance is a purchase out of your
budget immediately what baby step do you
put car gasoline in not a baby step you
put it in your budget you need car
gasoline to run your car you need to
take care of your children if something
happens to you and so life insurance is
an immediate purchase for you so who is
going to take care of the children if
you were to pass away
thought he had domestic violence issues
yeah he
he is custody due to the fact that the
domestic violence is against me and not
my children
um that's encouraging it was just you
yeah I feel so much better that's me
yeah that's sarcastic oh my gosh
hesitation for a few months and then
they deemed him fit so in the event that
I've passed um unfortunately
they would go to him and as someone who
has filed bankruptcy twice
um I don't thrust what he will do with
that money no he doesn't get the money
he gets the kids
right okay so there is if I were to go
and speak to someone there is a way you
would leave you would have the
beneficiary of your life insurance be a
trust and the trust would be managed by
a trustee which is um someone you select
that you trust with money and to do your
wishes and the trust would say something
like uh the children can have the income
off of the investment what do you make a
year
about forty eight thousand dollars okay
so if you had a five hundred thousand
dollar policy and you instructed the
trust to invest that in mutual funds and
it made fifty thousand dollars a year
that would replace the income that
you've created you probably don't need
that much because hypothetically this
guy's actually going to feed these
children anyway so but you know let's
just say that you did a
48 000 okay so four thousand dollars a
month if it made four thousand dollars a
month you could distribute that to him
as child support and he gets a monthly
income from to take care of the children
for the good of the children as long as
he is taking care of the children he you
know the money goes where the kids are
so if the kids get uh the state comes
and takes them because he commits
domestic violence on them then the money
would just be you would instruct the
trust to keep the money and build it up
for when they're an adult
okay that makes sense but you don't give
him fifty thousand dollars or five
hundred thousand dollars right right you
give him monthly income to help Feed the
Children because he's not capable of
even managing his own money so we need
to send some money over there for food
what a disaster
this is not ID this is not this is not
fun for me I don't
I don't love the idea of the kids going
over there and I really don't go I love
the idea of the kids going over there
with money but I would rather them go
over there with money than without money
yeah
um it's not been a fun four years for
sure yeah so like if God forbid
something were to happen how old are the
children they're five and seven
they're pretty young yeah
um
like obviously that's my concern and my
parents don't live in the United States
um so I wouldn't be able to make them
like a
executor they could they could be they
can be a trustee they don't have to be a
U.S citizen to be a trustee
they could be
in charge of the money yeah you could
leave them as the trustee
okay it could be someone who does not
live in the country necessarily that was
my other concern was doesn't matter
they're not a U.S citizen okay they
don't have to be they're managing money
on behalf of a trust not on behalf of
themselves so you know if you go to mama
bear legal forums dot com you can get a
what's called a Family Trust form and
get a will and the will says that the
money is gonna and then buy a life
insurance policy from Xander insurance
and make the beneficiary of the life
insurance meaning where the money goes
upon your death the name of that trust
the Sarah trust I'll call it okay and
it's there the the big chunk of money
whether it's three four hundred thousand
dollars is about all it needs to be here
uh goes into that and then instruct your
parents to invest the money as the
trustees and to disperse a certain
amount of money per month to him as
child support
okay and if he no longer is managing the
children the trust no longer sends the
money to him
so if he were to
well I guess this is hypothetical we
don't know okay so I mean would your
parents take the children if they could
sleep being from a different country
myself included
um it's a bit trickier I've
entertain the idea of moving back home
but
um he would not allow it but I think in
a hypothetical where his back was in a
corner
um and they were my parents would be
willing to yeah
um take them yeah so I mean I want to
stipulate a bunch of things there that
as long as they and if they end up
taking care of the children because the
state takes the kids from him at some
point then they would also be receiving
the money from this trust I want to make
sure these kids are taken care of that's
all we're doing here okay so that's the
purpose of life insurance is to replace
the care through money that you give
your family
and so if a guy's making you know a
hundred thousand dollars a year and his
family is eating out of that he needs a
million dollars in life insurance
because a million invested
at making 10 would be a hundred thousand
dollars a year we've replaced that guy
if he dies we replace the income that
he's creating we replace the guy but we
replace the income that he's creating
that sets him up to be able to win or
sets the kids to be able the family
that's remaining up to be able to win
financially and um not make more money
than they would have made with him here
but at least replace what he was doing
in your case sir she what she was doing
replace what you are doing to care for
these children income wise because your
ex is obviously not responsible enough
to send you money over there so you're
taking care of these kids
um he's not responsible enough with
money he's not responsible enough with
his own emotions uh this is just not a
good guy there's nothing in this story
that sounded exciting to me for him oh
I'm so sorry sorry you're facing all
that but Mama Bear legal forms get your
will and Trust in place Xander Insurance
get three four hundred thousand dollars
in uh life insurance it's not very
expensive but the cost of a pizza and
you can make that fit in your budget
especially as you get out of debt and
start to have more and more margin so
God bless you honey sorry what you all
have been through over there open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five some of the most courageous
people in the world are those that are
the other side of a domestic violence
situation
and I'm an old redneck hillbilly I don't
even like the phrase domestic violence
it makes something extremely horrible
and rage inducing sound very lame it's
not lame at all it changes family trees
it changes it puts a curse on a family
that is unbelievable that can only be
broken by the power of God I mean it is
a it is a nasty mess when somebody's
engaging in that stuff and sadly in the
world we're in we get to see it fairly
often
and it just still just I'm I'm just an
old redneck it just pisses me off
it's that simple this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with a daily practice of meditation and
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this is a
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace
remember hallow is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Charlie and Katie are with us hey guys
how are you hey we're doing well thanks
better than we deserve I hear you
welcome guys where do y'all live we live
in Chandler Arizona which is a suburb of
Phoenix absolutely good to have you all
welcome to Nashville so your ktsa
listeners Maybe
no no you didn't listen to a song on the
radio there okay because that's one of
our biggest reasons on YouTube yeah also
YouTube YouTubers all right that'll go
well YouTubers will like Ken's sweater
today yes and so does Baskin Robbins and
so uh oh Dave with the jokes uh this is
gonna be good good show today good day
this is gonna be fun I can just tell
all right guys how much debt did you pay
off we paid off 335 000 330 how long did
this take 60 months wow and your range
of income during that five years started
at 200 000 and ended at 292 000. whoa
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
registered nurse I guess you are I'm a
financial advisor of course you are
that's perfect what a great combination
two great careers obviously doing very
well at them 335
000 did you pay off your house
I love it I love it very cool so what's
this house worth
it's about eight hundred thousand
of course it is and Mr financial advisor
how much is in your Investments about
nine hundred thousand with about 50 000
in precious metals and cryptocurrency I
love it so here we go other than fifty
thousand you've been really smart well
done
great job guys I love it man so a
million seven right yeah net worth and
how old are you guys I'm 49. I'm 52. and
you did this by 50 years old wow look at
you I'm so proud of y'all way to go
that's so fun okay tell us what happened
what started this journey with paying
off the house thing five years ago yeah
so Dave our journey really started back
in 2012
um after about 10 years of marriage
unfortunately we found ourselves in the
middle of a divorce and uh yep and as
you can imagine that's a pretty
difficult thing to go through you too
yes sir oh wow yeah so and uh at that
point a good friend of mine had
recommended a a Ministry that you may be
familiar with called Divorce Care
absolutely I went through divorce care
and uh they teach you about things like
how to deal with anger and loneliness
and depression and all of the fun things
that go with the train train wreck
called divorce and as a part of that
um you're in one of the segments
actually yeah in one of the versions for
financial peace
talking about things like how to stay
out of credit card debt and use a budget
wisely and things of that sort so the
program was exceptionally helpful for me
it really softened my heart and so much
so that even though we were divorced and
not living together at the time and
whatnot um I mentioned the program to
Kate and she attended you know three or
four months later
so
um and at that point we um you know
after two years of being fully divorced
we got sitting around and talking one
day that you know how did we end up in
this situation what happened to us and
what if we had gotten a second chance
and part of Divorce Care and the
wonderful part of that Ministry which we
have now been a part of for the last
seven years is reconciliation and by the
grace of God and the power of Jesus
Christ we
were able to reconcile and restore our
marriage after three years of being
divorced and so that's just been a real
blessing for us one of the
non-negotiables for us when we got back
together was we never wanted to end up
in this situation again so
um getting our finances in order was
certainly going to be a Cornerstone of
that of that process so we attended
Financial Peace University back in 2016
or 17. as part of the reconciliation
process correct to get on the same page
correct which is what reconcile means
exactly wow look at you guys whoa what a
journey
so going into the original divorce what
percentage of the marriage problems were
money problems
money fights
good percentage yeah okay yeah I think
we were pretty normal
um you know it's the number one cause of
divorce it certainly didn't help
anything
um I mean we made a lot of mistakes
along the way
um we bought a rental property with a
HELOC we you know used to take trips and
spend you know wildly with credit cards
and things of that sort and while I
would say that the money issues were not
the primary cause of divorce they
certainly did not help that's for sure
yeah put extra stress on top of stress
correct and coming together gave you a
common language as a part of the whole
reconciliation process yeah wow yeah
that is a great story I love you guys
you're amazing what a fabulous life
you've built oh man and a healed a
healed life yeah there's a lot of
healing that goes this is this is a
wholeness uh this is not somebody that
tripped backwards into this you walked
headlong into it yes sir and it's been
it's been a while now so we we got
divorced in 2012 and we reconciled at
the end of 2014 almost three years later
so we've been together since
nine years remarried correct yes yes
okay wow and how long were you married
prior to that nine and a half okay so
nine on each side so far okay all right
good deal wow wow and your kiddos are
with you what are their ages uh Pierce
our oldest is 16 and Nina our youngest
is 14. okay so they were around through
every bit of this yes they experienced
both sides and the middle they did they
did yeah wow they did what a thing
you've done for your family tree not
counting the money even but just the
whole thing the healing this is
impressive yeah it's uh I'm really
struck you know by the emotion
um and and that has to be so rewarding
to be standing here today at the Finish
Line knowing that you guys did what very
few people will do which is actually try
to reconcile much less actually do it
I'm curious
what did the FPU getting on the same
page with money and when you guys
finally got back together how did that
affect your Communication in other areas
of your marriage now that you're coming
back and going we're giving this another
shot uh definitely made it much better
we were more focused we had a common
goal moving forward in that kind of
bound us together and everything moving
forward Rowdy love it yeah I would say
it definitely improved our communication
so I like what you said in the in the
divorce care video about when you start
off up with a budget you're going to be
terrible at it the first month and then
get a little bit better month too a
little bit better month three and that
certainly was us and uh we we met on a
weekly basis I'm the nerd of the you
know the financial advisor the family so
um you know those meetings used to last
an hour and a half then an hour then 45
minutes so on and so forth now we can do
a budget meeting in about a minute you
know two minutes or something like that
so
um but it really did help to improve our
communication and I would say that when
we were apart or before we were apart
the first time we were married we had
separate bank accounts we had one joint
account for you know dual bills and so
forth but then we both had separate
banking accounts but combining
everything now has just really helped us
out tremendously and just throwing
grenades into the other account all the
time yeah
over there yeah I'm uh I'm curious to
know did this debt-free journey have a
tangible effect on you all making more
money
I think without a doubt I mean I think
uh we didn't have peace in a lot of ways
prior to getting
divorced
um and now I'd say that you know we
certainly don't fight about money we
don't fight about
you know anything like that anymore so
yeah no we're on a different it's a
different level of communication and
understanding and relationship indeed
yeah it's a whole different whole
different set of people yeah be not
conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
you guys are impressive I Love It
Fabulous wow what a fabulous story all
right bring the kiddos up they need to
be in the debt free scream they they got
to be enjoying this uh the end result of
this journey anyway so excellent work
hey we've got the live and give box for
you the baby steps millionaires book The
Total Money Makeover book The Financial
Peace University and you can give that
to somebody because I'm sure you're
constantly ministering to others now you
can't keep yourself with that Journey
from doing it so I'm so proud of y'all
thank you for sharing an amazingly
inspiring story uh it's just your Heroes
man I mean you faced some real demons
you really faced them down and run them
out with a stick man that's just uh
that's beautiful just very very
impressive very well done all right it's
Charlie and Katie Pierce and Nina they
got out of debt but that's only a part
of the story 335 000 paid off house and
everything baby steps millionaires
redeemed lives 60 months making 200 to
292. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
ah they're freeing so much oh my
goodness powerful this is the Ramsay
show
all right
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
thank you
[Music]
thanks for listening America Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
Matthew is with us in Fort Worth Texas
hi Matthew welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dane thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um my father has uh retired and owns a
small RV park and he recently asked me
to use my buying power to buy another
property to mimic uh the RV park that he
owns but on a larger scale
so I I've recently made an offer on a
home and put earnest money down but I'm
just kind of rethinking the whole thing
and just wanted to get your opinion on
that the home the home and property we
are purchasing is listed at 295 we paid
295 for it
the home is where the second RV park is
going to be
yes
okay
um
I'm a little bit confused uh he he can't
afford to buy another RV park so he
wants you to buy one for him
well he knows that my buying power is
capable of buying a bigger piece of land
since he doesn't have a job anymore he's
retired so he knows that as far as
buying power I can I'm not buying for
power borrowing power
right okay right borrowing power is is
bigger anyway so we could get a bigger
property and the investment overall
would end up paying more
yeah but that would be yours not his
correct so the terms he was going to say
is he puts the initial infrastructure in
to get it
um they get it making money and paying
for the the mortgage of the property and
we would spit any split any profits
above the mortgage of the property 50
50. mm-hmm
okay are you interested in doing this or
do you feel obligated to consider it
because it's your dad
I am interested I think that the
property is beautiful that I've I've
frequently hung out at the RV park that
they own and it's a really nice
lifestyle uh really good people that you
meet you get plenty of opportunity to
spread the word
um to lots of different people and I
think that the security that the cash
flow brings in just just brings the fact
that if I broke my leg at work I
wouldn't you know my children wouldn't
starve
well you're married
yes okay
and what does your wife say about all
this
um she I'll be honest she is willing to
follow me into whatever I get us into so
I I don't think she would voice it even
if she disagreed with it but so far she
seems like she's down to follow me
wherever I go
yeah
well if you break your leg at work your
kids aren't gonna starve and then your
language follow me into this I think is
a pretty good indicator of how you see
this
right I don't think you think this is as
good as idea as your dad does you see
risk he doesn't see yeah
I see it I see a payment that is a
little higher than I can currently
afford uh it's not much higher than I
can afford but I think it is higher than
I can afford and unless my dad is
willing to immediately come in and Fork
over the money and we get renters in
there quick to where the the cash flow
is coming I don't see a problem in it
but if man if we get out there and
there's no renters then but we're in a
big problem you know yeah and the
infrastructure could be almost as
expensive as the property and your dad
doesn't have any money
well he does he does have he has enough
to lay the infrastructure and I'm a
plumber and we have electricians in the
family so we do the work ourselves
um we've put in four RV spots in a
weekend and then rented them the very
next week for 450 a spot so I have no
doubt that for 35 40 000 we could lay
the infrastructure for 10 to 15 spots
Okay so
now you're in partners with your dad on
a piece of property that your home is on
and also contains a business that you're
in a partnership with your dad he
doesn't have the money to do all this
but he has the money to put up a little
bit of money for some Plumbing
raw materials and you guys dig your own
ditches
right he he has the money to do the
total infrastructure I mean what is that
um I estimated about 40 000. yeah is
what the infrastructure will cost and he
has plenty to cover that yeah there's a
rule in business it takes twice as long
costs twice as much and you're not the
exception
right these are the three rules of
business
okay so uh
uh this is this this has got about six
different places
that it can go wrong in only one place
it can go right so it's really scaring
me
okay your dad is a Salesman and he sold
you on this and um
you know you're not a PO you're not
opposed to the concept if the piece of
property was separate from your home it
would remove one of the six problems
but if this goes sideways you got a
bunch of half-baked RV crap in your
backyard
right of your home on a payment you
can't afford that's what happens if this
goes sideways uh if you're uh God forbid
something happened to you or something
happened to him
and you weren't able to complete this
plan and manage this business now the
home where your children live is at risk
this is
um
and
uh
yeah
I I see their working model and they
have a premium spots you know they
charge seven to seven fifty for their
spots
um it's a really beautifully done I have
no doubt that slowly we could get to
that point but we could get in
quickly that pay 450 a piece and um or
not I mean it might be that you have no
appeal whatsoever and no price you'll
get them in there
yeah well I've done some research in the
area every park nearby is full there are
two major lakes right on either side of
us within 15 minutes on either side of
us and um and it's a it's a beautiful
area it's four and a half acres well I
will tell you the rules that I run my
life with and then you get to decide
what you're going to do okay number one
I don't do Partnerships
the only ship that Won't Sail is a
partnership
because uh because of all the Deeds that
can happen the D's are default
disinterest
drug use divorce death disability and
you got to think about what happens in
every one of those cases with both of
you
what happens if your dad gets disabled
what happens if you get disabled what
happens if he decides he doesn't want to
screw with it anymore
what happens if he just decides he
doesn't like you
um what happens you know what happens
what happens what happens all you've got
is an entrance strategy you have no exit
plans whatsoever because your only
assumption is is that this is going to
work and that's not how business works
uh so you have to have you have to have
a uh so number one I don't do
Partnerships number two I don't borrow
for business under any circumstances and
in a very real sense you are here number
three I don't combine where my children
and my grandchildren and my puppy dog
and my wife lives with my business
property thereby if the business goes
bye-bye my family's homeless
that's a violation too so there's just a
bunch of things here that you're willing
to do that I'm not willing to do
and you called me and so my job is not
the kitten to be a dream killer my job
is to be a nightmare preventer
there's a difference in being a dream
killer and a nightmare preventer and
there's so there's a whole lot more can
go wrong with this Matthew than go right
I mean it everything has to go exactly
as planned for this even work and
nothing ever goes exactly as planned I I
couldn't do it because it violates about
four different things I refuse to do and
there were six words that he said
towards the end it's more than I can
afford
and that's where we humans certainly
Americans is how we get into this debt
the student loan debt the skyrocketing
credit card debt it's more than I can
afford that's the end of the sentence
wait get to a place that you can't
afford it's more than I could afford the
conversation should be over there and
we've got to as adults and I'm guilty of
this we've all done this week we want it
but we can't afford it we got to go if
we can't afford it it's done you know
you gotta walk away I can't afford it
Conversation Over
it's it's hard though it is absolutely
you get caught up with a family dream
here and working together just sounds
fun until it's not fun
so
uh Matthew I've given you all the
warnings if you go forward anyway at
least address those
and do it in a document that everybody
signs this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
laughs
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality and career and jobs expert
number one best-selling author host of
the Ken Coleman show is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so Ken my PR team just sent me this
you're going to love this one okay car
HP
uh written by a guy named Nathan Dyer
expensive cars from Finance personality
Dave Ramsey's car collection oh so
you're gonna love the cars I own that I
don't own
um
not a single one of them on here I own
never seen those never seen these cars
uh you just come this guy just makes up
lies this is literally made up I've seen
your cars yeah this is so fun okay
because I would like for you to have a
few oh yellow Corvette here okay there's
a 1934 DeSoto that's my favorite I would
I'd love to see you and Miss Sharon roll
that around yeah yeah here's a Mustang
oh that's cool a 1966 convertible
Mustang I'd like that ah man I wish I
had that car yeah yeah I wish I was as
cool as he thinks I am 1948 Chrysler
Town and Country convertible with the
wood paneling panels I don't have that
car either you and Sharon would drive
that to the pole 1959 Jaguar XK now that
is oh that screams Dave Ramsey only he
doesn't have it you don't no don't have
it
you know you could think he'd actually
get one of them that I own right correct
and you have a killer one I've got some
nice cars but none of them made his list
wow so you know but you know Abraham
Lincoln said everything on the
internet's true he did so he did that
tells you what's going on yeah and um
man I I I am
I I am much worse than I am in person if
you read on the internet and I'm much
cooler on this guy's site than I is that
a real is that a real site that's a real
site yeah yeah it's got a car HP and
it's got you know famous people
supposedly with their famous cars and
there's my little picture and the whole
thing and you don't even look happy he
didn't even pick a happy picture which
if you own those cars you'd be putting
up a Perpetual scowl okay so it's fairly
easy to catch my scowl that is
completely made up I can't even believe
I'm looking at that that is that is
complete that's so fun
gosh if I wouldn't if I wasn't me I'd
want to be me
there it is there it is
I should have somebody write up an
article of all the fake cars I own yeah
great I could really impress my parents
yeah people I mean and all my high
school friends hey look at all these
fake cars I earned I'm gonna get calls
from insurance people now I know you are
wanting to ensure this portfolio of
vehicles that I do not own this is so
great that's that's really great dude if
you would work as hard telling the truth
and working as you do it lying you could
actually make a living really true the
creativity there yeah I mean you spent a
lot you spent a lot of time I mean he
probably knows how to actually build a
website and stuff but instead spends his
time being a fraud if I was going to
come up with fake cars you owned I would
have thrown in a souped up El Camino
for me because I'm a redneck that's what
I mean a nod to the ante a car that
tried to be a truck and couldn't yes
yeah you didn't even like try to go back
to your to your roots oh man at least he
didn't accuse you of owning an electric
vehicle there's not a single ball they
would call at least he didn't accuse you
of owning an electric at least you don't
own an electric car it either the
complete fraud if any of them were
electric you're right oh my
great call out there good call James
yeah open phones at triple eight eight
two five wow be careful what you read
folks
I just wish I was as cool as all Nathan
Dyer says I am uh Steven is in Athens
Georgia hi Stephen welcome to the Ramsey
Show
how you doing today Dave great man how
can we help
that me and my wife have got ourselves
into on how we're gonna get out of this
hole that we've created okay
so little backstory recently sold a home
in Southern California we made great
money over there about 200 000 uh on a
whim we just picked everything up and
moved up to Athens Georgia in that to
Clinton jobs that were well paid and uh
moving to where
not paid as well anymore for the work
that's up here and um bought a home
immediately over face time I would never
recommend that again but uh yeah moved
into the home and when you look up
impulsive in the dictionary your
pictures there
yeah about about 42 days from visiting a
friend to a house being sold and being
here
including jobs that we've had for 15
plus years okay
all right so California refugees in
Athens Georgia all right
interestingly that homie
homie and uh okay
no sir nor did inspections
Okay so
ourselves into some credit card debt
and uh obviously the home and then cars
that now we no longer I guess can say
afford
that we were able to afford in
California now you couldn't afford them
because you didn't pay for them but okay
we could well be correct so what do you
have on your cars
all together about 72 000. okay and
break that down for me car number one
uh
car number one I think I owe about fifty
thousand on okay car number two is 22.
if it's 72 then oh you have three cars
okay
all right correct three cars uh one of
them's about twenty thousand and then
the other one's just about paid off okay
all right and uh what do you what is
your household income now now that you
got new jobs
about a hundred and ten thousand okay
and how much is your new house payment
twenty one hundred and how much car how
much debt have you run up other than the
cars
about 27 000 in credit cards okay to do
the repairs on the home or just just
because you bought stuff
we use try to use the money that we had
left over after selling a home and
purchasing a home try to keep a good
nest egg and that didn't work out a lot
of that money liquid cash had to go into
the home right away uh so you got no
money left
no money in savings no sir
all right
well you can't afford a fifty thousand
dollar car you need to sell it
okay period even if it was paid for
understood you make 110 you don't need a
50 000 car when you make 110.
pretty simple okay it's out of range now
unless you're going to see your income
coming up dramatically in the next 12
months you need to get rid of that car
you probably need to get rid of the
twenty thousand dollar car too and just
get you a couple beaters to drive until
you get this mess cleaned up so what
happens is we have to cut stuff until we
get the budget Back in Balance because
you're not in Congress
right
and so you know you gotta you got a 110
000 Top Line and we got to make the
bottom numbers fit on inside of that
with a working budget and that's going
to mean selling at least one of those
cars and getting a beater gets you a
five thousand dollar car and that's the
moves I would make
um and um you know we'll help you with
the process hang on I'll put you guys
into Financial Peace University it's our
class to show you how to get right side
up and how to become a millionaire later
uh but one of the things we're going to
teach is quit being said that blame
impulsive this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there one
guarantee and
and whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45 percent off
rules and restrictions May apply
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five George is in
Sarasota Florida hi George welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hello gentlemen thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
so um moved with my family to Florida
two years ago left my business in
Washington state and it's been there in
Tacoma Washington for about
five years and in the last couple years
trying to you know work remotely
managing the business it was a struggle
we bought a piece of property here we're
planning to build
and uh you know a month ago the business
burned down basically completely and now
I'm trying to figure out what to do next
as far as
um maybe you know we saved up about 120
000 plus the land is worth about a
hundred and uh we are thinking either to
start something new like a business that
I was doing there which is Auto Wrecking
um on the smaller scale or for me to
just get a job being more stable sell
the land and buy a house which is what
my wife wants us to do and we have three
little kids
five three and uh eight months old
I assume you had good insurance
I had no insurance business was
struggling and um
uh yeah so you just lost it for me today
I lost it yeah pretty much
some stuff survived but I would say like
90 was lost yeah so so what's the land
worth because you owned the real estate
right
um I did not own the real estate it was
um my landlord had the insurance for the
building
so but the land I purchased here we were
planning to build on is worth about a
hundred thousand
and we have 120 000 in savings and
you're renting your thinking yes
okay
what would you do right now if you could
just snap your fingers with the skill
set you have knowing your industry that
would pay you the most what would that
be
um there are a couple options
I have um maybe going into Consulting
for a company auto company or uh I
honestly like work for myself my whole
life 36. and um
I don't know so do you do you have trade
skills
um I do have trade skills what are the
work in a body shop as a tech as a
repairing cars and I can do get I can
get back into that what what was the
actual business was what you said it was
Auto Wrecking
yes what's that mean so that's uh
recycling
um a junkyard it's like a junkyard yeah
okay yeah but I was doing more of like a
indoor auto wrecking which was partying
cars out selling used auto parts okay so
you would buy a total Car parted out
sell off the scrap and sell off the
parts
correct indoors
and when you were in Tacoma and you all
lived there and the business was
flourishing
what did you make what was your best
year profit taxable profit
about 150.
okay
all right
um
what does it take to set that up well so
you lost up there you lost tools and
some inventory
in the fire
what's it take to set the business up
and get it running not counting the land
in the building
um it would take uh some tools some
equipment uh yeah like 50 Grand 40 Grand
like
probably around there yeah yeah
okay what I would do if I were in your
shoes
is I would take some side gig hustles
hustle and grind to make a living and I
would go rent an uh a warehouse
somewhere not and I would sell your land
now if you sell the land you got 220 000
bucks right
correct okay and we take 50 out of that
and now now I've got 170 to put down on
a house
okay okay and um I'm gonna start the
business in a rental property not owned
a piece of real estate this time I'm
going to put insurance on it and you
know how to make 150 000 a year parting
out cars on on the inside
of a warehouse right
yes and uh you can get to doing you can
turn a profit within 90 days of doing
that can't you
yeah yeah I figured you could because
that's a quick turn business you have
you have the uh you have the access to
the supply of the totaled vehicles and
do you have a distribution for the parts
Part them out you know how to get get
them sold right quick because you
weren't doing that on a local basis
you're doing that on a national basis
National and international yeah we're
selling yeah the part the parting out is
a it's an internet function right
yes correct yeah okay
this is not like some good old boy in
Sarasota wanders in and buys a
transmission from you you're parting
this sucker out you're sending a every
little piece all over the dead gum world
out of this thing and you know exactly
you know that you know the cars and
you're a gut without even asking that
have the parts that are in high demand
so you know what to buy
and that's correct yeah because the
parts on that particular vehicle will
sell the parts on the other vehicle
won't sell so I don't screw with it
right
that's 100 yeah you've got this is his
skills it is this is the issue that I
want to address real quick is the
relationship issue your wife wants you
to get us what she's calling a stable
job that means a salary and so you've
got to play you've got to think through
that what is her concern what's her big
concern because I agree with Dave you
can absolutely do that I I would be
working in some trades and and I'd I'd
ease into it a little bit based on
what's happened but I want to know what
she's so worried about
um she's worried about me being home and
having less stress
um because I had to leave well we we
decided to leave to Florida and I had to
work uh from home why did you move to
Florida
it was uh just something we wanted to do
like bullcrap why did you move to
Florida
okay so there is a little bit of
politics my it's closer to my wife's
family okay and uh better for our kids
there you go okay that's fair yeah
that's a good that's a good answer yeah
all right
um now uh
yes so I'm with Ken you know you can
start that you can do the parting out on
the side at first until you get it up
and running but you can make more doing
this than you can any trade job or any
side hustle agreed
yes this is the way you make your family
the most money is reopen this business
and run it but don't get in the real
estate business be in the park business
rent the dadgum warehouse from somebody
let them deal with the real estate like
you did before this time carry Insurance
on your stuff for God's sakes but other
than that yeah and and so you can drop
50k there you can set 170 aside for a
house start talking about when we're
going to buy the house actually the
truth is that you may want to rent for
two years and establish a really good
income as a self-employed person to
qualify for a decent mortgage out of
this particular business but you're not
you know you've got to get that business
really rocking for two years to be able
to use that money to qualify for the
mortgage because you're gonna have two
years of self-employed income to prove
it out
otherwise you're going to be making
60 or 80 doing a trade and that's the
base of the house you're going to buy so
if I'm you guys if I can get my wife on
board I'm going to say let's get a
rental and have a two-year plan I'm
going to work my tail end off we're
going to get this out get this business
up and running and then I'm going to
quit the side job and run the business
full-time I'm going to come home at five
o'clock and I'm gonna I'm gonna hire
staff and people working for me so I
don't have to be gone all the time and
we run a business during a normal
business hours and we grow it and we're
going to make 250 uh because we're going
to staff up and we're going to run you
know hire some marketing people some
tech people as well as some people to do
the actual wrench turning and let's get
this thing up and going in three years
from now you ought to be making serious
money that's that and buy a house with
170 down or 150 down keep 20 as your
emergency fund but yeah you're you know
considering you had no insurance and
considering you didn't have a good plan
before you've got a lot of good options
and it really does in great financial
shape minus the insurance issue yeah
exactly and if you to have the insurance
you've been another 50 you had or
whatever it is or more yeah that's
that's
lesson learned lesson learned this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
thanks for joining us America
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey Nicole and Perry are with us on the
debt free stage in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions hey guys how are you good
doing good good welcome welcome good to
have you so how where do you live
uh Amherst Massachusetts ah cool welcome
to Nashville okay and uh how much debt
have you guys paid off three hundred and
five thousand dollars okay and this took
how long three years exact years all
right excellent excellent so if I've got
my notes right you're coming to join us
yes you're going to join the Ramsey team
yes just happened wow all right what are
you gonna what are you gonna be doing
I'm a product manager on the coaching
team oh very good actually okay all I
see the team is out there they're very
excited to have you so what that means
is we're not going to ask your income
okay
so uh 305
000. what kind of debt was this
everything from business debt to car
debt credit cards family loans house
Improvement loans yeah everything
everything yeah so tell me uh you're
normal yeah how long you all been
married we just hit five years yeah okay
so two years into marriage normal sucks
yeah and how'd you get connected to us
and then end up working here too
crazy story so I came across you like a
decade ago
um I think I just found a book uh but
didn't really like just listened didn't
really tried my best to follow it but
met him and um once we met and got
married we were just like living the
life
um and then covet hit and he had his own
business and lost the business during
covid so that's when we were like we
lost almost everything
um and that was when we're like hey
maybe we should follow this and that's
kind of how we got on the the plan was
when we lost everything because
everything was going fine we were normal
up until then the income disappeared and
all of a sudden uh what you thought was
smart turns out to be stress tested yes
and didn't look smart anymore yeah
absolutely I mean we always were banking
on the business being able to continue
and to be able to pay the lifestyle and
then
you know the business went from making
about 60 65 000 a month to zero because
of the lockdowns and so
all of a sudden the lifestyle caught up
to us and we realized it was it wasn't
sustainable we couldn't do anything we
almost went bankrupt and so what are you
doing now Perry I'm in um marketing on
email specialist okay all right so you
can just transfer that when you guys
moved to Nashville without any trouble
yep okay and get back to making some
bank again hopefully yeah was that your
business that no I was I actually owned
a gym so I actually had a personal
training studio in Philadelphia oh
that's a good way to get completely shut
down during code yeah so it was not the
best business yeah Philadelphia shut
everything down well in those little
covets they don't like people that work
out it's true they were yeah they get
those covets are mad at people that work
out oh wow guys I'm sorry sorry you went
through that but I'm so happy you found
the light at the end of the tunnel yes
yeah and when we actually scheduled the
The step-free Scream
she hadn't applied yet it wasn't even on
the radar we kind of just put it out
there to kind of get full circle and
then
we were looking at hosting FPU classes
and so I was on the website perusing
just
you know looking at all the different
things you have and then I was like let
me look at the careers just for fun and
then saw a roll
um and I actually just wanted to do a
coffee chat to learn like what is it
that you're looking for in a product
manager so then I can tailor my resume
to like be what you're looking for or if
there's anything I'm missing I can go
out and then get that experience and
then try when I'm ready so a coffee chat
ended up to interviews and then it was
like you're coming down let's you know
see if we can speed it up and then yeah
we uh if you stepped into the tractor
beam yeah and it's been a great
experience so we're really excited way
to go very cool well welcome aboard
welcome to Nashville and congratulations
all right now you've been through hell
and back what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is
I think like constant communication we
like we listen to the podcast every
single day for a couple hours a day and
would constantly dream of what things
would be like once we pay everything off
and
um you know we we when he lost his
income we were only on my income and so
we basically were like we gotta live
everything's got to be within my income
so then when he did get a job
um all his income is what helped us pay
it off within three years because we
could live on one income
got your lifestyle way down yeah and
we've sacrificed a lot like it's not
like we were living the life still it
was we sacrificed a lot gave up a lot
um and it was a tough three years but
worth it in the end yeah I think
intentionality was huge you know just
being able to speak about everything and
have a plan and know this is a season
that might be a long season but it would
be you know it'd end sooner than later
if we just kept to the plan and so I
think at one time I had seven jobs that
I was doing I was doing anything that
someone would pay me to do I mean almost
anything and anything moral and legal
yes yes and so we just stuck to the plan
and we you know always communicated and
even in the hard times we tried to you
know understand where we were in that
journey and visualize where we were
going and
we've finished wait you know way way
sooner than we thought we would it
sounds like Perry you were working a
whole lot that's a big sacrifice but
Nicole when you were talking about a lot
you extended that that vowel sound uh
I'm curious what were some of the
toughest sacrifices that you guys made
so one of our big debts was we did van
la for a little bit so we bought a
sprinter van a 4x4 Mercedes Sprinter
um and flipped that so we had to that
was that's what is what kickstarted it
we were like we have to sell it like and
that was like a big sacrifice it was
like it got punch it was like oh look
we're living this amazing life and then
um to then be like it's gone and we made
that sacrifice to sell it so that was a
big chunk that helped us a lot
um and then yeah we didn't eat out we
didn't do anything there were um times I
got invited to my friend's Bachelorette
and I was like I'm really sorry I can't
afford it and I have such Amazing
Friends they were like come it's okay
we'll we'll cover you like we want you
there so like that was amazing as well
but the humbling yeah but we had to say
no and I think we've become the annoying
people that say no to everything and
we're cheap and whatever but
um I think at one point it sunk into
when things were starting to turn around
and when we were in the van you know you
have cheap utensils and cheap you know
things to cook and we literally never
even bought a new spatula we were using
this broken plastic spatula that could
shoot things up and we went to Target
one day and bought a spatula and we go
we did it we made it
our drinking glasses were when we would
get spaghetti
drinking glasses so when people came
over we were like sorry we don't have
glasses and we have people being like
come on guys you can buy plates because
we only had like four and he had dropped
a few and and they were like come on
I get in trouble for that the sacrifice
was Perry dropping place and people are
like you you can afford that like you
can get plates and we're like we yeah we
could but then I
this as well and this as well so
it's like where we're sacrificed a lot
um and even for our son we have a we
have a baby boy it was you know he would
go to deakin we only had like three or
four outfits and we're like sorry we got
to do laundry like we don't have
anything like we that we sacrificed a
lot in that sense as well that's awesome
yeah he'll never know
you know Dave there's a whole lot of
no's there that are going to lead them
to a pretty big yes here in just a
moment yeah and I think that's a great
lesson you guys are awesome
congratulations we're honored to have
you on the team and honored to have you
as family members here and uh absolutely
incredible we've got the baby steps
millionaires book for you The Total
Money Makeover book and the Financial
Peace University
uh membership as well you'll have all
those things when you're here anyway but
you can give them away and your son's
age and name uh Levi and he's 14 months
oh he is cute he's a baby commercial
and point out he's got a very clean
outfit by then yeah
freshly laundered outfit yes Nicole
Perry and Levi from well formerly from
Amherst Massachusetts now from Franklin
Tennessee 305
000 paid off in three years count it
down let's hear a debt free scream ready
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that's the way to start a new job it
really is it's quite a start it's very
good stuff this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your home for
Home Services if you're moving you have
a long list of to Do's but neighborly
has local Pros like house Master 5 Star
painting window Genie and Junk King to
check items off that list visit
neighborly.com and schedule a home
service expert near you today's question
comes from Alex in Oklahoma I recently
changed jobs for a pay increase to get
us through baby step two it's the same
role at a new company my previous
employer said that they could not make
me a count offer but last week I heard
from a co-worker at that company that
they may reach out to me to see if I
would come back they may try to match a
new salary or maybe even increase it I
was wondering if this is a risky move
I'm concerned that I might be a Target
if there are layoffs since I jumped ship
I enjoyed working with my old team but
left for the large pay increase almost
50 percent is this concern rational if
so what can I do to lessen the risk well
there's a whole lot of Maze and maybes
and I heard this you know it came from a
co-worker so until the old company
contacts you back Alex this is all
speculation let's start there but if
they were to contact you and you had
this I think it's a legit concern
because you know if someone left me if I
was the owner of a company and someone
left me I would be worried that they
would leave me again and that's that's
you know a reasonable worry you left for
a big pay increase but it but I would
just bring it up to them if this happens
there's a whole lot of maybes in this
and so if they call you back they want
you back you can explain hey I left I
needed the money I was paying off debt
that's a very reasonable explanation uh
and in the interview process just say
hey have I uh created
um some concern for you do you think I'm
loyal like I'd bring it up in the
interview and look them I bought eyeball
and allow them to address it you know
address the elephant in the room and if
they go there's no elephant uh then then
you're fine but I I wouldn't worry about
it unless you know they say that they've
got concerns about you leaving them
again
now I'm interested to know your thoughts
on that because you know people leave
we're a large company you know any
company has people move in and move out
what's your take on that
if they wouldn't match the salary before
you left
the fact that they're coming back now
and doing it makes me not want to work
for them
so I wouldn't go back
and we have a rule at Ramsey our rule is
we almost never
rehire
because in the times that we have
rehired in our world we're not in a high
turnover World we're in a low turnover
world I got a friend that's in the
restaurant business he rehires all the
time but they have 125 turnover a year
so they rehire people they don't you
know they work seven different places
and they cycle back around it's uh but
that's a different world this is a low
turnover world I'm in and what we found
over 30 years of running Ramsey is that
the reason that someone left the first
time will be the same reason they leave
the second time
and so yeah I agree I think that's
awesome so we don't re-hire except in
very rare circumstances
um so 99 of the time it's no I think I
have two people out of a thousand that
are on their second round here at this
moment if I remember right I can name
one of them and I there's another one in
the back of my head somewhere but um and
we actually call that guy unicorn yeah
he is because he's pretty rare he's a
fabulous team member that's right so uh
but his nickname around here is that for
that very reason because it's unusual
for us to rehire
um and uh so anyway the
but also I would reverse that in your
case and say for the very reason that
they didn't take care of you before you
left is the reason you don't want to
return
you know they didn't step up they you
had to wait until you're gone
and then they're like well guess
because you're right you're the first
one back out the door
when you get back over there you're in a
tenuous setting I wouldn't go back I
think you're I think you made your
decision you moved on you got a 50 pay
raise I'd stay stay where we are yeah
and just say thanks guys I appreciate it
that's nice I wish we'd had this
discussion before but we didn't and I'm
not cool you know if they make the offer
on the spot then that's different yeah a
lot of speculation in this too and I
think he needs to be focused on the now
where he is and let's move forward yeah
and quick you make a good point you know
quit jumping around on every penny that
somebody throws that that's 50 is not a
penny but if they're going to just match
what you did and you're going to go back
you know no yeah I mean if they want to
give you 50 of what you got now we'll
have to talk about it I guess but you
know but if you all you're doing it's
not yeah you'll be careful yeah because
we know that following the great
resignation was the great regret that's
correct millions of people uh went to
another job and they went oh this isn't
what I thought it was going to be or
what I was told there's a lot of that
going on yeah yeah they told me I could
you know I work for zoom and I could
work from home and then Zoom says oh
even Zoom is coming back to work in the
office that's the greatest
irony in the history of the world but
yeah so a lot of fun a lot of Fun open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Katrina is in Boston
Mass hi Katrina what's up
hi Dave hi Ken thanks for taking my call
I am a new listener to your show and I
am just kicking myself for not listening
earlier I feel like I've never really
learned to adult when it comes to my
finances so I have a lot to learn
um I am a 45 year old single mom by
choice that means I decided to have my
children on my own using a sperm donor
and I say that so you know I'm totally
financially responsible for my two kids
they just turned one and three they're
little babies
um and I'm really feeling anxious about
our financial future and I'm just a
little bit paralyzed about what my next
step should be I have a chunk of money
in savings and I don't know if I should
pay off my mortgage what's a chunk
um about I have about 250 000 in savings
of the kids right you know it's a good
chunk they each have about eight grand
in their in their accounts as well okay
um and how much do you make
about 145. okay and what other what
debts other than your mortgage do you
have
none just my mortgage I just got a
payoff quote on it because I have a
feeling you're going to tell me what's
the payoff
it's 97 or 98 it's not much but here's
my complications
um I I bought my house a few years ago
from my father
um I bought it for 150 and it's a great
deal at the time it was probably worth
350 now I think it's about worth 6.50
um but it's falling apart and it also
came with two little rental units so the
whole thing together is probably sell
for around 650. and everything is kind
of old and falling apart I'm constantly
putting money in to fix things never
mind trying to get ahead on some of the
repairs that I know will need to come
soon the other complication they have is
that I have a very long commute to work
I'm I'm a high school teacher a high
school vice principal and I spend
between three and four hours a day
commuting right now so my kids are in I
know my kids are in daycare it's fine I
spend an absolute Fortune to you know
pay people to take care of my kids for
me so I I know at some point in the next
few years I'm either going to have to
get a new job which I don't want to do
or buy a new home that's closer to work
so I just don't know what to do with my
money and how to set myself up for
success in five years where did the 250
come from
just my savings you're Frugal you know
amazing uh I guess yeah yeah I mean you
lived on 250 000 less than you made over
a period of some years
that's impressive well I'm 45.
you're not 85. you just I mean this is
amazing you did great received the
compliment you rocked Katrina you're
doing great man I would sell the house I
would sell your house today yeah and
move closer to the district and pay cash
oh I okay I can't sell the house because
it's a family house but we are very
attached to who's we
me and my parents I'm not attached to it
it's a house allowed me to have the kids
that I would not have been able to have
when I was renting an apartment in
Boston you know so
it served its purpose
you sell it even with the rental unit I
would sell it the chances of me
commuting three hours a day is precisely
zero for more than 10 days that's gonna
kill you it's gonna suck you're more
obligated to this house and you are
spending time with your children
oh I know but I know I hear myself a
house okay okay it's a stupid house
if you gave your children a gift that at
first was a blessing and later became a
curse because they didn't want you to
feel bad you didn't give them a gift
and you wouldn't do that to your kids
and your dad didn't do that to you sell
the house it's a house
this is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay wedding go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality and number one best-selling
author of the book from paycheck to
purpose all about careers and jobs he's
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dane is in Denver hi Dane welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey welcome to me yeah I just I've
always wanted to say this how are you
doing Mr Ramsey better than I deserve
what's up man
hey uh yes I have a really quick
question hopefully
um I'm looking to make a lateral move in
housing from one house to another I
currently own my home that I live in and
I'm looking to make a um
flight move not not too far away and um
I see it as two different options that I
have I'm trying to avoid getting
another mortgage out I'm trying to avoid
moving into a rental temporarily I'm
trying to avoid storing all my stuff I
like to just go from one house to the
other
um I see it as I can do a sale on
contingency
or what about these we buy your house uh
services are they a scam or not
well they're not a scam but they're
buying the home to resell it at a profit
which means they have to buy it from you
at Below Retail
right
um
yeah the money that I would lose on that
would probably pay for the rental first
how do you know you know I I've done a
little bit of research I know renting is
extremely high here
um and I do work with a lot of
appraisers
um in the line of work that I do I'm a
land surveyor I mean all of this is all
of this is assuming that you think you
know what they're going to offer you
correct correct
um I've actually reached out uh just you
know you can fill out those forms email
kind of forms and
um none of them have responded with a
number which kind of shocking I mean a
little weird yeah exactly it's because
they don't want to scare you to death
they want you to sell them a house but
dude I mean it's usually 80 cents on the
dollar 70 cents on the dollar
oh wow yeah so it's not it's not a small
it's not like a two thousand dollar
discount or something
I mean it's a lot yeah you're not so
desperate are you
no I'm sorry don't do it don't just
don't do it here's what you need to do
you just need to be patient and do a
contingency sale
okay let's see I like that yeah I'm not
going to do it otherwise okay I sold my
personal residence when everything
peaked out
um two years ago because it was a real
killer opportunity to get out of that
house and uh but we sold it and delayed
possession by four months
okay okay and that gave us four months
to get the other house purchased
and moved into
um and but that you know well uh did you
take I didn't take a discount I just
refused to sell it otherwise so you're
gonna refuse to sell your home out from
under you
you're gonna sell it on some kind of
terms that allow you to make a one move
all right and then the person I'm buying
it from they also have to agree to this
too correct yeah I mean but what I would
do is start shopping the area that you
think you want to be in and say I could
live there there or there and if you
want to make an offer on one of them
contingent upon the sale of yours fine
typically what most markets do there's
differences in different markets it's
generally culturally uh except the real
estate Community for some reason decides
it in just culturally in a market but
most of the time you'll have like a 72
hour first ride of refusal so if the
seller
of the other property that you want to
buy accepted a contingency offer from
you it will be contingent upon the sale
of yours and they keep theirs on the
market
if they get another buyer you have 72
hours to say I'll buy it anyway
and you wouldn't do that you would let
them go
right yeah okay yeah I you're right I I
do have time on my side I'm in no rush
and so if until the right deal comes
together and the right timing for you to
buy the home that you want and move one
time with the sale of yours on a
contingency sale you just don't do it
well they won't they won't take a
contingency contract okay can't buy that
house yeah yeah all right I like this
idea and I can just uh just take my time
it's all out of convenience kids got a
new school down the street and yeah and
just what you do is you just you know
I'm gonna carefully line The Dominoes up
so that when I push them they all fall
and make that beautiful design
wife and I can do that we've uh
yeah we're totally debt free we
um own our house I'm 42 years old you
know I'm I'm I'm sitting pretty yeah and
the trick is to not get married to the
purchase house
yeah yep there's only one if I don't get
that one to hold it no there's lots of
houses you can purchase right so if you
don't get married to a certain house
then you say I want to move over there
and I like this kind of a property and
whichever one God arranges for this
whole domino system to fall I'll land in
that and I'm gonna be happy as a clam
now the second thing you got to Born
yourself against and I have to worry
myself against this too and I'm in the
I've known done real estate my whole
life is when you've got everything lined
up
and then someone comes to buy your house
you're you see you're emotionally
motivated to get that deal done so we
can push the dominoes and if you're not
careful you'll discount your home in the
negotiation process because you get all
excited
right and just be aware of that that's
human nature
yeah I got all this lined up and you
know I don't really want to take that
late little amount but I want to push
the dominoes and uh now you're about to
take ten thousand dollars too much less
two less than you should have so just
just play hard to get and don't get
married to the next one and you can line
these up and you're gonna be just fine
and folks I want you to know that Dave
Dave practices what he preaches in a lot
of areas but you did that on that house
and I got to tell you we're thinking
about you're talking about the house and
I got to tell you I'm missing that porch
I don't know how you got rid of that
house with the Porsche that you had
highest point in Williamson County yeah
I could see 18 miles off of it and I I
just you took me back there for a second
it was beautiful I'm being selfish
that's beautiful I kind of missed the
Hangouts out there and the night the
nice people that bought it from us they
paid me for that view yes they did and
that is the moral of the story folks I
mean I I thought you were a little crazy
but it was a good book it was good it
was a little crazy but it was if you're
ever going to sell a particularly unique
property during a super the hottest time
I've ever known in 35 years of real
estate would be the time to do it and
you did and I did it right at the top of
that market so it's just you know these
fall evenings and I you know I'm yelling
at somebody all the time on here it's
just a house and then yeah but those
that that house that views on that
property
astronomical yeah that's astronomical
yeah I do miss that although I'm nestled
down in the woods now where I've got no
view which is amazing too you like that
very quiet comes back in Walden Pond
here you know so all right little I
expect some new poems from you Dave
there we go yeah puzzle cell those poems
will be big redneck poetry is a big deal
you know hillbilly poetry poems of Peace
that's it from from the woods of the
Hill I've already titled it yeah there
we go it's um the next book who knew I
was gonna do another one we just decided
yeah this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
my friend Willie Robertson is the CEO of
Duck Commander and Buck Commander and
star of a E's Duck Dynasty and they've
expanded his family companies from a
living room operation to a multi-million
dollar Enterprise
Willie spoke with us at uh entree
Leadership Summit about business and
Leadership did a great job back in May
and he emailed me the other day with
this film that he's done about his dad
and his mom's early days and uh it is
and then sent me a link to it I intended
to watch just a little bit of it so I
would be intelligent on this interview
and I couldn't turn it off it was
absolutely fabulous Willie how are you
my friend
doing good man you're making the rounds
pitching a movie huh
sitting here in New York City you know
how it goes doing this thing yeah so you
on Fox this morning
I wasn't no that didn't work out but
we're working on some other stuff for
later on yeah I've been pretty much on
the phone or on the computer or uh being
interviewed all day long so it's a big
week which is coming out so uh I'm not
going to read the film synopsis I'll let
you just tell the story uh but uh I knew
a little bit of the story from talking
to you and talking to your dad and your
brothers over the years that your dad
was basically a Hellraiser and uh and
and had an amazing uh experience talk
talk through what the film's about
yeah it uh yeah so the timepiece is set
in the 50s 60s and 70s uh so it's and I
want to make everybody aware it's not
Duck Dynasty that's the aftermath of a
family that's that's got its way right
and uh has a strong safe and this is
right at the beginning uh this is where
that really lost his way and uh uh just
really it's been about 10 years just
making making life really rough for my
mother and that's his kids and uh and
then it's a story of his Redemption and
how he found the Lord and uh and how
more probably more importantly how Mom
forgave them to keep the family together
um you know David if that hadn't
happened my whole life would be
completely different and uh you know who
knows what would have happened I
probably wouldn't be talking to you
today so uh because that's out of that
came the company out of that in the
business Duck Commander from that came
down Dynasty and then you know and all
the things that have gone along with
that and so we can trace that back to
this this really spiritual moment I
think you'll realize when you see the
movie man how close it was you know just
to be in over you know completely over
so uh yeah it's a it's a powerful story
and the display one we had that really
need to tell
Willie kin here I'm just curious was
Phil reluctant to share this story in
movie form he just comes across as a guy
who's just so humble and just a plain
spoken man I was curious to to know what
he's feeling about this story being told
he really was I mean they've been so
transparent throughout their whole life
like there's nothing in the movie I saw
but I hadn't heard them tell us directly
and they've been really open about their
lives but I think once they got down to
like making a movie and we're gonna you
know pretty much highlight the worst
time of your life you know that was a
struggle and I'm so glad he did and you
know we're talking Christianity and
really just generally in life I think uh
to not look back your past is over look
forward you know press forward unless
they make a movie about it which was
going to live forever right so uh so for
him mom to really dig back into the past
and uh deal with that pain but you know
what it you know he said if it's if some
somebody if one person comes to the Lord
over this or saves a marriage or you
know can help shed some light on stuff
and he was willing to do it and that's
just yes kind of guy he is and uh so
yeah it was it was difficult and it was
really hard for us to watch I mean it's
just hard to watch you know your your
parents like my kids their grandkids you
know uh tar for all of us going to watch
watch me with that pain that they went
through
yeah well until the story arc hits its
peak and uh the story is so well told uh
not only is it a great story but it's
well told the screenplay and the acting
are they're lights out man I mean the
guy playing your dad has got the
Louisiana accent down God I thought it
was Phil a couple of times he sounds he
can do voice-overs for Phil
he's from England no way that's great
yeah well he's good he's good man he's
even from America yeah isn't that
amazing how those yeah you know really
all the cast and how they put that you
know how they when they showed up and do
what they do it's just it was amazing
just putting a story the hardest part
today was to make it not rated R because
Phil's life was really rated R
it was hard to make a face-based movie
about a guy who pretty much fell
overview has wants nothing to do with
faith so uh but that's the gritty story
you know that's where that's where we
all were you know we're all we get
ourselves in these situations and so
yeah we just wanted to be real and raw
and honest and say hey this is it this
is what life looked like movie comes out
9 28 the 28th of September this week
it's called the Blind and it's set in a
Duck Blind him uh talking to one of his
friends who's asking him how he turned
his life around and then he he takes you
back through the history as he's telling
his friend the story and it is uh it's a
great setup a storytelling mechanism is
absolutely good and I'm blown away this
kid's from England because I got to tell
you man I thought he was a swamp guy I
really did he he completely sold me and
when that preacher baptizes your dad in
the movie in the in the swamp water and
he comes out uh screaming about Jesus
and loving Jesus I got tears running
down my face it was I emailed Willie But
Ken I said I'm not crying you are yeah
Dustin Dusty in here yeah something
something in the allergies are bad this
time of year yeah yeah so I know I know
what Phil wants Phil wants people to
meet Jesus that's Phil's whole thing in
life everything he does about that and
as you guys put all of this together
what was the overall goal for the film
I mean really does
and it's the same thing I mean we were
one coming to tell this story and Corey
and I got into production really to tell
stories and we just saw the power that
Doug honestly have we just we I mean
just thousands of people telling us you
know like what this what the story meant
what the what the TV show meant to him
the prayer at the end just the dinner
table all that so we were like hey we
need to put more stories like this out
we didn't particularly work longer to do
our stories but but this was just such a
story that we decided to put this one
out and uh and so yeah that was our goal
was just to you know say marriage has
helped people and then and tell the
story then look we're we're no different
you know I think you can see people on
TV and it looks like we've got it all
together it's like oh they don't have
any problems and they got money and
they've got you know and we just wanted
to show you no our life is just like
yours and also having spent time with
the current version of Uncle Sai seeing
the youthful version of Uncle Sai was
mind-blowing
ain't that fun that's one of my favorite
parts to see it because that's what I
didn't get to see you know I didn't get
to see that girl and I didn't get to see
young uncle's side little kid Uncle sign
I thought those moments were real fun
and the moment with Bradshaw too you
know because because Terry Bradshaw and
Phil played attack together and Terry
told me that story the story we have in
their field taking Terry fishing Terry
told me that story he was doing
autographs and I I think I was like 13
years old and he said hey let me tell
you this story about what your dad did
to me and so we put that story in the
movie which is really fun and and let's
let's not miss that folks if if you
didn't catch that he's talking about the
Hall of Famer the legendary Terry
Bradshaw and Phil hanging out together
no no Phil was the quarterback Terry was
the backup I know but I'm saying they're
hanging out he quits because he wants to
duck hunt right so Bradshaw becomes the
quarterback right and Phil's duck
hunting instead of in the NFL how great
is that but just imagine those two
having conversations those are some
characters yeah and the movie portrays
it
how do you get tickets and movie
information for the Blind Willie uh yeah
you can go to uh theblindmovie.com and
find out more about it you can purchase
tickets now
um and you can rent haul a theater you
can get together to church and you know
here's the deal guys we only have a week
in the theaters you know if it does well
they'll they'll keep it longer obviously
and um uh so I think we really got to
make a statement you know the Hollywood
and everybody else can make movies and
says hey these are the kind of movies
and we've seen such successful movies
you know juice Revolution sound of
Freedom Movement some great ones so uh
yeah go support it yeah all right the
movie is the blind check it out at
theblind.com uh see you soon my friend
good luck with this and God's blessings
on it
thank you buddy see you soon be good
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
open for again
[Music]
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money on
the debt free stages Scott and Rachel
hey guys how are you
let's try again hey guys how are you
we're doing great how are you guys doing
better than we deserve where do you live
we live in La Verne California which is
just outside of Pasadena all right very
cool welcome to Nashville and how much
data have you guys paid off we paid off
377 thousand seven hundred and eight
dollars all right how long did this take
it took about five and a half years good
for you I love it and your range of
income during that time
uh well we started around 160.
um I made a career change right at the
end of 2019. covet hit I was a wedding
planner no oh no so we dropped to about
140 and then I picked up a ton of jobs
so we increased back up to 220 working
about seven jobs at one point
are you back to wedding planning now I
am yes good thank God better than seven
jobs yeah wow what kind of debt was the
378.
um so about 15 000 was uh cars uh 20 000
was credit cards and then another 340
000 with student loans wow yeah Wow way
to go guys student loans Galore yeah yep
wow for what I went to uh I'm a
pharmacist so I went to pharmacy school
which was very affordable okay yeah sure
yeah and what and what did you pay how
much of the student loans were yours all
of them all pretty much all pretty much
yeah 300 000 for pharmacy school with
interest rates and everything yeah
holy you got ripped off oh my gosh wow
okay wow well congratulations you're
there now and you got a good income
that's good yeah so you plowed through
this what happened five and a half years
ago you got out of school got married
and went oh my God yeah so what's funny
is um my parents put my brother and I
through Financial Peace University in
high school so I had the knowledge going
into it um but we really didn't discuss
finances until premarital and I realized
we were not on the same page I had fbu
in my back pocket Scott did not um and
he was against it so when we got married
he came to me and said I want this TV I
knew we couldn't afford it and I
actually went to my dad and I said what
do I do like he wants this TV I don't
agree and he was like look tell him if
he'll do FPU with you
you can get the TV just just make it
that and so he agreed that is all about
bribing yeah yes he agreed in by the
second class he was hooked and no TV
yeah I was uh to be honest I was very
skeptical
um I was not on board initially even
after the first class of FPU I was like
yeah we'll see like let's see how this
plays out
um and then the second class uh everyone
had to total up their debt that they had
and we added it together as a class and
with my wife grasping my like clutching
my hand I realized we had 90 of our
classes debt and so we needed to make a
change oh wow so that hooked you yeah I
was like okay group shaming yeah
I was like how is this possible like
what whoa we got a lot and we got almost
all of it yeah
just I have a relationship question on
this given how this has been set up so
when you've realized that and you go
it's done like how quickly do you tell
her is it on the way out is it in the
car on the is it at home it was in the
class it was in the car it was oh the
last day it was like continuous
conversation afterwards I'm in yeah
that's awesome yeah yeah so when you
flip the switch you flip the switch I
was all in yeah those of us that are uh
cynical I'm the same way I have the gift
of cynicism
um I'm either all in or I'm all out yeah
and so uh once I'm out I'm out and once
I'm in I'm in yeah yeah and it's it's
game on yeah there's no ish yeah I
either think you're I either think
you're selling snake oil or this is the
best thing since sliced bread yeah once
I started crunching the numbers I was
like yeah I'm in I'm in let's do this
let's just game off game on let's go win
the Super Bowl so five and a half years
later you plow through your student
loans this is an ironic debt free Scream
the week before student loans restart
yep yeah I mean big Sunday black
Sunday's coming yeah uh this this Sunday
is when they start back for everybody
and you've got a 378 thousand dollar
story here yeah that you guys plowed
through and it was really your first
order of business and marriage right
after a TV yeah you know priorities yeah
well that's it I guess yeah I guess the
TV came in handy because you guys didn't
go out you were either working or
sleeping eating that was pretty much it
yeah you still have the TV so I'm
grateful all right that's good move wow
good for you guys very very well done
I'm proud of you excellent excellent
stuff so what advice do you have to
somebody that's got a big old pile of
student loans and they're facing it for
Sunday because this really is a week
honestly we can joke around about it but
it's it's a scary week for a lot of
people because they're having that
realization that Biden is not coming and
they're going to have to do this
themselves they signed up for it and
they're going to have to pay it whether
you agree with it or not doesn't matter
that's your reality and folks are scared
and they're confused they're overwhelmed
I mean that's a big old mountain that's
Mount Everest 378 000 you come out you
write that down you go I have an oh crap
moment yeah so what's your advice to
somebody sitting where you were sitting
five and a half years ago I think for me
it's just having open communication
about finances just being able to come
to your spouse Allison just say you know
what like this is what I need this is
what's important to me this is what we
need to start thinking about and just
having that dialogue and being on the
same page
um what helped us tremendously to be on
that same page is having a monthly uh
budget meeting yeah we sit down every
single month we go through our finances
we go through everything that's expected
and potentially coming up and we're able
to work through it yeah and for me
um it's funny Jade was talking about it
last week actually is celebrating the
small wins
um I know that the life cycle of getting
out of debts only supposed to be 24 to
48 months and ours was five and a half
years and it's a long time to be under
that amount of stress and we tried to
take every opportunity we could to just
celebrate the small wins we made an
Instagram page with our dog and we would
form our payoff for the month in his
kibble and he would then eat it we'd
film him eating it
we named him the debt free dude because
he's a doodle so yeah
all the doodles yep and um Scott was
always really great about just finding
little surprises to celebrate um when we
got under 100K he set up this fake game
show in our backyard with lights and I I
fake money I had to throw a baseball to
break the paper to see what our New
Balance was it was it was very elaborate
we had photos of it but
um just celebrating that stuff because
it's hard to see the light at the end of
the tunnel if you aren't celebrating
okay real quick that's brilliant and and
because I've read a lot about there's a
lot of research on gamifying goals yeah
and that's what you guys did and that
really did help you get through each new
hurdle because the brain goes all right
we have something to look forward to in
the midst of all this struggle that's
really brilliant I love that we had I
don't know eight different loans eight
different student loans and so every
single time one we were able to to pay
off one it was like okay like we're down
one we only have five left okay we have
four left and so on and so I think it
helped a lot and last thing for anyone
fighting that large of a mountain of
debt give yourself Grace
um
it's easy to get upset if you have a
slower month or you feel like you're not
moving as fast as you can and just know
that you're not going backwards you keep
going forward and you'll see the light
you guys are heroes yeah how's it feel
sorry I don't know
hey we've got
the makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book and the Financial
Peace University membership for you to
live or give in the live and give box
way to go guys we're very proud of you
Scott and Rachel Pasadena California 378
thousand paid off in five and a half
years 160 to 220. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it
yes it's amazing this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today second chronicles 15
7 but you take courage do not let your
hands be weak for your work shall be
rewarded
herb Kelleher said the world isn't going
to shower gold coins on you just because
you have a good idea you're going to
have to work like crazy to bring that
idea to the attention of people
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Mark is in Cincinnati hey
Mark welcome to the Ramsay show
hey great to be on here good to have you
how can I help
uh I just had a question about uh
building credit
um I just don't know where to start
um I'm currently a student I'm 23 years
old I am graduating in three months debt
free
um I don't have any like I said I don't
have any debt I just don't know where to
start with building credit why do you
need to build credit
uh because I'm trying to move out of my
parents house in the next three to six
months that doesn't require credit
um
from my understanding I know that most
renters want a line of credit or not
true or at least want some kind of
credit history it's not true that's a
lie that your friends tell each other
okay well well that's why I'm here I'm
here to get some good advice so here's
the thing everybody says that in order
you have to have a credit score in order
to run an apartment and yet we routinely
will pick up the phone and call 10
apartment complexes in any given area
and say hey I'm a student coming out of
college I have zero debt and zero credit
um will you rent to me nine out of ten
of them say yes
and yet all of your friends tell each
other that you have to go get a credit
card to build up your credit because no
one will rent to you but the truth is if
you actually call to an apartment
complexes two of them might not but so
what
the other eight will
some of them may require a slightly
larger deposit which you get back if you
leave the place in good shape and pay
your rent
but you know don't fall for the Trap
Mark the Trap is is that you have to go
build a FICO score and the way you build
a FICO score is you go in debt why do I
do that so that I can borrow money why
do I go into why do I borrow money so I
can build my FICO score why do I build
my FICO score so I can borrow money why
do I borrow money so I can build my FICO
score why do I build my FICO score so I
can borrow money and you it's a dog
chasing its tail and suddenly you're an
American making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and one hundred percent
of your money goes out to some stupid
but bank because you worshiped at the
altar of the great FICO and that's what
your friends are doing and some of your
their parents are doing but it's not
smart and it's also not factual
yeah well that's what my brother said he
said that a credit score is just an I
love death core well it sounds like he's
been listening to the Ramsey Show
he has he's actually been on your show
before so what's your future look like
you graduate then what
yeah
um
well I graduate uh in December and then
I'm actually going back to school for a
second bachelor's which I only have two
classes left for so by May of the next
year I'll have two bachelors and then
I'll be looking at master's program what
are you going to be doing for making
money to be able to pay this rent
uh right now I'm working uh full time
and then I'm all I also uh work kind of
part-time in the independent contractor
uh doing group counseling sessions
because that's my that's what I'm going
to school for I'm going to be a
addictions counselor okay so you're
gonna get your master so you can get
licensed in the state of Ohio good for
you yeah okay yes so I'm already I'm
already licensed as an addictions
counselor in the state of Ohio I'm going
for a they don't require a master's
counseling
no uh so the way I did it
um you you just need a masters for
higher uh credentials which is that
that's what I'm going for
to why the second bachelors
uh just because it's only two crosses
left you I see right you just check it
off it's within reach yeah that makes
more sense okay and so the the I'm just
curious I'm not questioning whether it's
right or not because I just don't know
uh but the second Masters higher
credentials enables you to do what that
you can't do now as a licensed therapist
uh so it's just um so right now I'm
licensed as an addictions counselor uh
but I want to be I want to go into
mental health counseling which requires
a higher level of schooling and that
does require a master that does require
a message that's that's what I want to
go into I mean they won't give you the
license without the Masters is what
you're saying
right so essentially my big goal in five
to ten years is to sound and own my own
uh counseling kind of
uh organization
holistic yeah good for you mental health
and addictions counseling to
people that are struggling I love that
you're working in the field while you're
going to get the Masters love that
that's a beautiful path it's gonna it's
gonna equip you beyond what you realize
not only are you making the money to pay
for everything yeah but it's going to
equip you very well done Mark very well
done and one other small practical thing
to consider Mark I mean I'll be right
for you but being single you're working
a lot schooling maybe getting a roommate
for that first apartment uh will also
help solve that perceived problem as
well get in save a little bit of money
you're still renting you're out on your
own but that's an option and something
to think about cuts the cost down yeah
Beverly's in Dallas hi Beverly welcome
to the Ramsey Show
thank you and thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well I'm a little bit different than a
lot of your callers I'm 74 years old
and I wish to goodness I'd started
listening to you 20 years ago but I
didn't so I'm starting today okay
um I have
about 32 000 31
959.26 to be exact and uh credit card
debt
and I know that I want to get busy and
as you say gazelle like and paying that
off
but I also have 57
623 left on my house
Dave I'm 74 and I'm in good health I
want to pay off all this credit card
debt but is it okay if I just continue
making payments on my house while I'm
still young enough and healthy enough to
travel and do things and then pay for it
I mean obviously continue making
payments but you know what I'm saying
yeah but the you know the more stable
your last your the the sooner your house
is paid off the more stable your last
year's will be
right and so um that's the trade-off uh
obviously you need to clean the credit
card debt up before we talk about travel
right okay but right uh and do you have
any money
um I do I I am I'm I'm retired and um I
have
like 425
000 and
um an annuity with a it's a fixed
indexed annuity with a lifetime Rider
yeah pay both the loans off tomorrow
do what pay both the loans off tomorrow
okay out of that annuity
and I have a about
forty thousand dollars in stocks uh
Textron and Computer Share stocks okay I
would cash that out and pay out and then
take a little more out of the annuity
and um and make sure you have an
emergency fund set aside and you're a
hundred percent debt free by the end of
the week no mortgage no credit cards cut
up the credit cards Beverly it's time
for plastic surgery not because you're
74 but because you use credit cards
my
my sister to help me and at the time I
asked her to help me I had about twenty
three thousand dollars in credit card
debt and her suggestion was to get a
credit card and have all my bills just
go to that end so your sister's not very
good at this
well there she and her husband are
millionaires which is why I asked them
her Theory took you from 23 to 32 so her
idea sucks yeah for me it sure did I'm
just saying I mean you need to cut up
the credit cards completely get you a
debit card like I use and like Ken uses
and a debit card you have to only spend
money that you have chop up all the
credit cards into little bitty pieces
take out that so stocks and enough out
of the annuities to pay off your
mortgage and your credit cards this week
be living on a budget where you don't
spend more than you make and you never
grow any debt back and travel the world
and have a wonderful life
we're so glad you called wow that was
easy yeah good for her having that money
set aside there it is she's going to
feel so much better about traveling
tomorrow morning that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show and the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]